un joli tapis blanc comme les
Californiens n'en voit que très rarement
de quoi émerveiller cette fillette et
son grand-père
[Musique]
mais le blizzard il sera faire la plus
de 100 km/h amène aussi son lot de
problèmes dans un état où les pneus
d'hiver ne sont pas coutumes
en matinée plus de 120 000 foyers
étaient privés d'électricité en
Californie seulement au neige
inhabituellement volumineuses se sont
ajoutés d'importantes pluies qui ont
fait monter le niveau des cours d'eau
dont le fleuve Los Angeles les craintes
d'inondation éclairent se sont
matérialisées dans le comté de Ventura
les eaux ont balayé ce parc de roulotte
et forcer les opérations de sauvetage in
extremis
de la Californie en proie aux
intempéries a été pris de cours par
cette dépression météorologique venue du
Nord qui a au passage des réglé le ciel
d'une partie de l'ouest des États-Unis
plus de 30 millions d'Américains étaient
toujours frappés d'alerte météo en
journée
Aria qui profite de leur premier flocons
nul besoin de s'inquiéter ils ont vite
fait d'apprendre les vertus d'une neige
collante de février ici Jean-Philippe
Radio-Canada Montréal